what up gamers today we are reacting to
other people reacting
to coffeezilla now some of you might be
confused steven why would you do that
well
recently guys i don't know if you
noticed we made it into the twitch
reactoverse okay what is that uh
basically they're a bunch of really
popular twitch streamers who will react
to your content if it blows up enough
and you know there's some people who
will get mad about this right they get
upset because usually these people will
clip the videos up to youtube and
sometimes they'll get a lot of views but
i really i don't care honestly i love it
it's kind of it's symbiotic because most
people who are watching them may never
have watched you and so you get exposed
to a bunch of new audiences but more
than that you know i've made reaction
videos myself so i'm not mad about it
it's a part of youtube and frankly all
i'm doing here today ladies and
gentlemen is i'm trying to get a piece
of the pie for myself so we're going to
react to them reacting to us and that
way we can sort of
judo some of the the views back in our
favor here let's react guys first
reaction looks like we got ludwig uh
reacting to coffeezilla big fan of
ludwig here been been an early supporter
big omega lols if you fellow twitchers
get my drift how do you do fellow kids
sorry i'm still working on the twitch
lingo oh this is actually one of the
early videos ludwig may be an early
coffeezilla fan that would be very meta
it didn't steal from small time streamer
ludwig so don't even look into that
those are fake allegations interesting
very interesting
it's not what it looks like guys me
having inspired copyzilla who is the
person who found phase k now just k to
have scammed people means
that i'm the person who caught k whoa
whoa whoa whoa
whoa does that math check out let's do a
little uh back of the napkin math here
i'll let him have it old school ludwig
fan i'll let him have this one that's
the transitive property in action baby
wow all right well that's first reaction
next reaction
gosh i'm so bad at this look i'm
learning to react guys good reaction
from ludwig i'd give that a uh 9 out of
10 reaction ladies and gentlemen you
guys have been begging me to react to
tech lead reacting to me
let's get it over with i'm not going to
make a full video about this let's just
let's just do this by the way button
this up hey guys welcome back okay let's
talk about coffeezilla you know this guy
is a psychopath okay wow this is a very
serious thing and coffeezilla is ruining
so many lives out there whoa what'd i
ever do to deck lead oh that may be what
i did this guy is mad it has become a
concern for me and for all of society
and i am concerned about the effects it
is having on the people who watch his
type of content
coffee they misspelled it coffee
that's good man i wish i had a beard
like that dude now before we go any
further i do want to tell you guys that
uh this whole video that we're watching
right now is all about how watching my
content will make you a broke depressed
loser but i do find it funny that tech
lead dm to me like a few weeks before i
caught his token to scam and said hey
your channel's been fire lately even
i've been enjoying to gaunt it and your
10 million dollar studio so to be clear
tech lead is a massive fan marriage is a
scam sure and people at coffee zilla
will probably remain virgins their
entire life screaming about how marriage
is such a scam while other people are
out there dating going out having kids
having grandkids and
wait i'm married am i not
of the two of us correct me if i'm wrong
i think i'm the only one married here
how am i saying marriage is a scam
i'm married what else does tech lead
have to say about me and in fact some
people have even alleged that
coffeezilla is actually a registered
offender whoa
isn't that the slander that he uh
deleted like on twitter then he's just
putting it up that's funny is he saying
that i'm a a virgin
offender i'm pretty sure those two
things are mutually exclusive i mean i'm
no biology expert but i'm pretty sure
you can't be
amazing interesting reaction tech lead
i'll give you a reaction six out of ten
not bad could have been a little more
consistent there next reaction oh hassan
we got hassan next ladies and gentlemen
this is my favorite rich socialist of
all the rich socialists i like this one
the best we get some easier
investigations some low-hanging fruit
here like more regular content i try to
get that out to you on those bigger
investigations thank you to all our
newspapers gosh i'm annoying here let's
get to get past me let's get to the
reaction dude i think that the reason
why these the reason why coffee still is
like exploding is because one he's doing
great content obviously every twitch
streamer watches videos like every
single one since he started doing
i wonder if it's uh if it's correlated
to that not me no no not me at all is
hassan responsible for our growth listen
guys this is what i said at the
beginning of the video i'm not mad about
people reacting because i actually think
it does help he's got a point he really
does because people get so upset about
i've seen other youtubers i'm telling
you this is a big gripe of youtubers
when twitch streamers react to their
content and i don't get it because i'm
like if 30 000 people are watching i
guess some people see it as like that's
30 000 people who won't watch my video
if they're watching their video but i do
think he's got a point where if all
these new people are watching your
content because these twitch streamers
are reacting to you
hello i have seen incredible growth when
everyone just started reacting to me so
i i don't think it's a coincidence i
kind of agree here you don't promote
viewership as much as you think
literally every single [ __ ] youtuber
says that when twitch streamers watch
them they [ __ ] spike well people are
saying subdim is he not subbed
assad let's be fair let's be fair am i
subbed to hassan okay i can't talk uh
hassan i'm subscribing to you you gotta
do by the transitive property ludwig was
talking about i'm pretty sure you have
to subscribe too that's the transitive
property in action baby good video by
the way shout outs out to coffeezilla
once again oh thank you thank you hassan
shout outs to you my man hassan is
actually a cool guy and uh he's kind of
right about the reaction stuff people
get mad but i agree i i think it's i
think it's stupid now our next reactor
we're gonna look at here is a guy named
xqc i hear he has his own language let's
figure it out when's the reacting start
dude when's the reacting started
oh all the potatoes and all these guys
wait hold on
go back to make sure that people don't
dump the coin automatically they're
making a system people can't sell all at
once so they were able the influencers
the people that are early to instasell
while all the other ones who were
holding the bomb couldn't dump the
potato the hot potato it's like a hot
potato incredible analogy this is
actually incredible i this is better uh
better put than i think i put it in my
own video and you're like oh my god i
have a hundred but that was my hands
like what you can do with this they're
all hot ah
right and then and then you're like i'm
just gonna dump them and system goes
dude imagine if my whole video was all
about potatoes the whole thing was a
giant potato analogy incredible you know
what i like this i like this keep keep
going
we're this is an agriculture channel now
and now the potatoes are put in your
hands and now your hands are all
completely burnt and that's their fans
burnt hands need i say more ladies and
gentlemen i feel like uh the hottest
potato right now thank you xqc very cool
reaction i think 10 out of 10 here by
the way i didn't read hassan's hassan 8
out of 10 reaction but now it's time
ladies and gentlemen to talk about the
reaction that i've been looking forward
to watching the most uh critical
bless you crypto scams is that the uh i
actually don't know about that i'm gonna
watch that is that from um coffee time
what what did this man just call me big
moist himself critical coffee time
is that gonna be my name now but
apparently the video from like a channel
called coffee time
hey
hey do we change her name to coffee time
if he yo what have we just changed our
name it's like don't even bother
relearning it we're just coffee time it
is i've actually heard that before
people go oh yeah like my friends
they'll be like yeah you run a channel
because a lot of my friends they don't
like watch a lot of youtube and they're
like yeah you just run that channel
right like coffee time and i'm like
sure too much reacting let's go more
more watching i like watching beginning
and the end of these things see uh how
it is cause i can't just sit here and
watch 17 minutes of a video with you
guys not only sold save the kids in all
right i've got the gist of it now wow
guys this this one hurt a little bit he
just clicked off the video what like 10
minutes in 15 minutes in all right p
listen guys you can't win them all uh
that i i'm just honored to be reacted to
by critical and yes i now will answer to
coffee time if he says it hey it's fine
i'll give that reaction an eight right
he didn't get through the whole video
that's okay but good good reactions guys
that there's your reaction what what'd
you think of it do i have a career in
professional reacting i felt a little
awkward doing it i'm not really used to
it but you guys can let me know good
kappas or um omega lull let me know in
the comments below thanks for watching
i'll see you in the next one